[Music]
a little bit of work minute don't scare
us i get up i go hard like i'm george
harris make plays break lanes push way
break
[Music]
welcome to a classic combat fight
campaign i'm joined with a very special
very colorful the number 12 135 on the
goddamn planet some say number one
fiesta's fan base it's suga yes sir sean
what's up brother cheers man cheers
cheers man
this uh i'm looking forward to this man
we're sitting down watching some of your
fights we're starting off with really
the fight that kind of set your career
into the goddamn outer space because
snoopy went [ __ ] nuts this is og this
is uh was uh week two
of uh dana white contender series season
one this is where it all started yeah i
think it was july i know it says look at
that baby face 22. how old are you now
27.
it's crazy the last five years still
young now before we hit play
i'm sure is there any walkouts or stuff
on uh not on this
[ __ ] so how did this come about though
because you were you had 15 amateur
fights how many pro fights have you had
this time i think it was six and or
seven and over here and then who got you
into the contender series the sugar show
himself i [ __ ] i knocked out i had
like one of the craziest knockouts in my
opinion
yeah the david
spinning kick inside um and i the ufc
they were they they were looking for
talent dana white's content they were
looking for me so did you reach out to i
had our manager at the time
and uh
and and i think that's i mean sean
shelby was supposed to be at the fight
now that he didn't go um
so i had a manager at the time that that
was close they got you in there yeah
and so
they give you alfred
ayton he was eight and three eight tkos
no punk no punk dude i felt like this
was a ufc
you know this was my first ufc fight i
felt like i didn't think it was anything
other than ufc no you should have ufc
caliber
i had the worst fight camp i've ever had
for this fight really what happened got
a concussion a couple weeks before the
fight training partner uh rob emerson i
think you might you know old school
bob's great rob i think i dude i
remember waking up living at a tiny ass
apartment with danny and like waking up
in the middle of the night couldn't look
at any lights puking you've had
concussions i'm sure like awful dude
concussions are the and i remember just
being in the back and uh the song wasn't
for me people were thinking yeah
thinking about shugo that's all i'm
thinking about i bet and so
you walk into this obviously now skinny
i was eating a vegan diet
don't do that no
look at me dude i'm [ __ ] i like i
weighed in at 136 pounds i walked in at
138 pounds and you know where you can
see is in your ass there everywhere yes
but
you know it's the same thing like
for people not to say this is a ufc
fight it's insane like when i found the
ultimate fighter like oh those don't
count on ufc fights i'm like well go ask
the two guys i knocked out and the one
guy submitted unconscious like pretty
sure that was a fight man yeah i count
those those are you [ __ ]
so
how nervous are we for this did you
realize how big of a deal it was i i
it's hard to say was so many fights ago
and so many years ago i don't remember
being nervous tim was in the back with
me was i very nervous is he a nervous
tim
you're not really nervous
this this was the worst fight camp hands
down ever dude and tim did you know uh
how big of a deal this was going to be
like did you know this was the if this
this is eight mile moment months weekend
we didn't think of it like that because
i was 22. so we were like i don't really
i before this fight i didn't care if i
got into ufc tells 24 or 25 like we
weren't in a hurry we really weren't my
skills
weren't there like right here i'm not a
top 15 player 100 like we weren't we
weren't thinking like we got this is it
it's our only shot i lose this fight i'm
back to johnny you look so young man bro
so [ __ ] skinny so young still good
movement and the counter still filthy so
you see that you see the talent oh my
god
no that was that landed like he poked me
in the eye right there and that was the
first time i've really been poked um
but that was a it was a very high-paced
fight right off the rip dude so and i
remember thinking like
i was completely on like empty after
this fight dude i i was so
sure emotionally but just like i i
wasn't in shape for a fight i really
wasn't you just admit you know my
grappling i'm pretty blue belt right
here i i mean i do throw them in a
shitty little triangle like i had
like a lot of these punches on the
ground i was i was pretty good at
defending like if you actually watch
where the punches are landing like
they're not really you're doing a good
job with your feet there
yeah it's not on the fence not mad at it
though yeah okay you gotta do what you
gotta do i agree
like let's see
but i think the biggest thing of that is
like okay i threaten off my back he's
gotta be aware yeah he can't just go
freelance there um you have fat joe in
the back that school is around yeah big
fatty
so you're trying to get you i need to
get the [ __ ] up here i'm like god damn
this is where he's finished eight of his
fights now in your head are you thinking
like god that's my opportunity matt like
i got it like i can't quite i really
don't remember thinking of anything in
any of these these spots uh i remember
being tired yeah i remember dude being
like oh [ __ ] i'm fatigued and have you
had fights go like this prior to this
never so this is the first time for the
first this is the first time i really
had show at any adversity i'd say and
his he's pretty alfred was good yeah man
do you ever wonder what happened to
these guys he got knocked out by sergio
pettis recently or not recently a couple
years ago bad bad yeah that's a nice
left hand right there i heard him with
that left hand
trying to counter his jab um
i was i was confident because i like i
said i've been fighting since 16 so i
had knocked out so many people going
into this fight
i was capable of they're not scared of
them right here
i
no it's okay right that was a close i
remember almost landing that and that's
what set it up that was a double jab
right hand oh ladies and gentlemen
a little elbow
he looks
stronger i don't lift i've never lifted
you're not vegan
but i have brian kellen's chest yes
and ass
yeah yeah but i let that double jab
right hand i almost landed earlier i
don't
know
popping
oh it's all for show though really yeah
i know
this right here
double jab right hand double jab sets up
it looks like you're setting it up too
oh right there a little couple stutter
steps
and then the right head kick
the right knee
and now i'm like okay i'm in control of
this [ __ ] fight i need to not grapple
right now my [ __ ] car though and his
face is [ __ ] he doesn't know where
the [ __ ] is that right yeah he's
concussed right now he's like okay what
the [ __ ] just happened
are you thinking your head hell yeah
let's get this guy out when i hurt
someone i finished i i i don't know i
don't just finish people right off the
bat i heard him first and then finish
him
so i have him hurt now it's all about
now it's just you know playing now
you're throwing different too and you
are landing like a [ __ ] yeah
it's just accurate ref almost stops the
fight
i love the faints too yeah slipping
uppercuts right here he's
he's throwing i'm slipping trying to
land uppercut what a slobber knocker
yeah
no that was a slobber knocker his
brother in like the audio you can hear
his brother yelling coach edmund [ __ ]
rhonda's
black belt
boxing coach slip uppercut yeah so i was
[ __ ] just looking for the
this this knockout right here got me so
many [ __ ] fans
yeah he kind of landed there but you did
it countered back
tried spin nothing finally sprawled a
little bit
circle back into the middle of the cage
yeah this people are like why is his
hands up that knockout like he didn't
even have his hands up like it's because
he's [ __ ] concussed yeah he's
concussing he's also exhausted right
here and there's dana in the crowd and
dana's still dude dana stands up anytime
dana stands up and you that's that's the
goal that's what this guy i've watched
this video so many times like watch you
what are you saying right there
i was looking for dana and i was i knew
i was gonna say welcome to sugar shows
my [ __ ] show so i climb up in the
middle welcome to the sugar show
it's my show
and see and i think too what's powerful
there is like i think dana saw the star
power there because think how many
fights that dude has watched there's
only one person who's watched more
fights than dana's joe rogan yep so dana
knows talent he knows the star when he
sees it and this was the beginning of a
[ __ ] budding star to say the least
that's crazy
i feel like alfred's feels better
because you've went on to do great
things yeah what i'm saying randy
whenever i got beat i always rooted for
the guy to like i'm like dude win a
championship yeah like go on and do it
makes you look better yeah for sure even
the guys like you know kill i'm like i
want to see them you want to win yeah
otherwise it makes your win look better
right yeah that's true but yeah no that
was a big one i mean right after that i
you know
they announced i got the contract and
then i go and smoke [ __ ]
with snoop dogg in his trailer and i'm
just did snooping
how'd that work yeah snoops like snoops
one of snoop's bodyguards came down and
said hey snoop wants to meet you so they
walked me out
or they walked me up to where snoop and
your eye were and then he has to
commentate the rest of the fight so i
met him real quick went back down sat in
the locker room and waited for all the
fights to get over then they announced
that i got the contract and then i went
out to his trailer and what cool dude
he's just congratulations it's hard for
me to even remember dude there was like
seven blunts in rotation so you never
didn't have one and i had stopped
smoking i knew i was getting tested so i
take a puff i'm already high now and i
just got to use the country and i'm
coming off a viral knockout that i know
is going viral one of the best moments
one of your best moments in your life
it's not the best well it's gotta be up
there i just don't remember it much i
was so [ __ ] sh i walked out of that
trailer with glasses on and like there
was the po
i was like wow where am i at the first
time i was around a bunch of cameras
when did it hit you that that was like
life-changing like maybe two days after
um i remember i was like oh [ __ ] tmz
wants to [ __ ] do an interview i threw
on my weed robe and grabbed like a
[ __ ] seven foot joint and like it was
just i'm like i gotta fly i'm gonna play
this role but i'm gonna i'm gonna this
is time to shine
yeah and then the contract you get off
the contender series what's that look
like so it was 10 and 10 straight off
the contender series they did not give a
[ __ ] they're like we [ __ ] up with sage
north cut we gave him like 50 50 and he
[ __ ] saw he ruined it so i was 10 to
10 off that
uh first fight then i fight um
uh at uh terry on wear
negotiate new contracts like 2020
um win that
new contract so
i was able to get not terrible
especially for like earlier yeah i
wasn't i wasn't and i owe and i i don't
necessarily disagree with the 10 to 10
sometimes if you're bringing on a guy
that no i agree they're investing and
they don't know they don't know he's not
selling twenty thousand dollars no
tickets like so i wasn't mad but you
know i remember after this fight i was
pretty fired up like what you're really
not gonna [ __ ] pay me yeah because of
what i had just done but i i do remember
i fought gonzaga for eight and eight so
bro hold my bear yeah
you've done well since at least yeah
some people are probably like still
[ __ ] oh yeah by some people i mean
majority yeah 99
so that's why it's an interesting fight
me versus eddie wine the ufc 250 so this
was this was a test for you man because
eddie weiland obviously fought for uh he
fought you're i have faber i fought on
the same card he fought for the wc
championship as well like also kind of
you could say wc legend yeah eddie
williams a monster man super vet
this knockout i think is when
i would say the majority of the roster
got jealous yeah
yeah this was the first time yeah i
think so first time i did my hair so i
was coming off this was um july 10th or
some [ __ ] i was coming off a two-year
layoff had two surgeries i just fought
oh
um i just fought um
jose quinones and it was off two-year
layoff first round knockout and then
they offered me eddie wineland i'm like
oh [ __ ] yeah that's you know another
which is a big step uh it was big i
think that was the ufc let's see what we
got here yeah a little bit of it i think
so too it was a perfect it was a perfect
fight because
yeah you see the dude's going to try to
[ __ ] fight kick box with me
agree and this knockout is so filthy man
yeah no this is one of the this is one
of the ones where it's like okay bottom
left like you got to be
you got to be able you got to be very
high level to to do the [ __ ] that i did
well he's also seen it all too easy
like he's been in the room he had
monsters he had seen it all but every
time i fight someone they've never seen
someone like me i'm just different and i
think that's the problem for these guys
that are fighting you it's like
they can watch tape but there's nobody
they're going to bring in into their gym
that can mimic what you do which is a
problem it's kind of like one boy
thompson yep it's like you can bring in
taekwondo karate guys but he just moves
in ways that you're not going to be able
to train for look at that [ __ ] hair
people this one takashi 69 was like who
is that that's the first time yet that
this that hair is
legendary [ __ ] hair dude like that
was are you going back to the rainbow
you think or no nobody lit now my girl
does my hair so i kind of let her i mean
we we both kind of talk about it and
decide depends what season what day what
year where we're at in life so there's a
lot that goes into the decision of the
hair i'm jealous of you here man i dyed
my hair uh kind of that color and it was
a complete nightmare yeah i i look like
the biggest uh gayest health angel
you've ever seen i look like anderson
cooper [ __ ] leather
and so i see your hair and i'm jealous
yeah i know it's uh oh that [ __ ] is lit
yeah the braids i mean it was like
that was
there was more i don't even remember who
the main event was the most thing they
talked about was my hair this fight like
going into this fight week was like holy
[ __ ] what's the statement yeah sure and
it was like i was like i have to do
something i didn't think i always think
i have to do something sick now i have
to that i'm going to do something sick i
knew i was about to do something [ __ ]
buyer and is this also the first time
with the face tats
um when did you were like you know what
let's go to the face after after shocker
mom fight i thought it was my first
fight on the ufc pay-per-view i felt
like a [ __ ] star and i got a star
tattoo on the face and then the rest of
it you got sugar you got the heart got
the sugar heart i got breathed up here
it says breathe if i look in a mirror
like it says it backwards
a little flower right there just [ __ ]
random and then you got the the
checkmate
oh yeah
yeah and then i got me shooting a free
throw or a little jump
so bad dude why not
you know i already look like your hell's
angel on stage it's just dude once you
think of something might as well get it
yeah [ __ ] we're all gonna die anyway
oh god you're so right dude i'm gonna
[ __ ] do it
[ __ ] i'll get one too [ __ ] um yeah this
fight was pretty cool too his first
fight in the apex
for me what a brilliant move by the ufc
oh you're gonna shut [ __ ] down small
we're just gonna run out of ourselves
it's like the ultimate fighter really
like there's only a handful of people
small cage which sucks i don't like
small cage bad for your style yeah just
calm very calm but urgent ready great
faints like keep it honest man your hair
looks [ __ ] great it look that that's
one of my dude i love that hair i'm sure
your girl's got more business over here
again she's uh yeah she's she's blowing
up very good yeah and she's like
she's a black belt hair i like to say
yeah
yeah but this was like a i remember he
lands one right hand this fight didn't
really i mean i remember feeling it but
i wasn't like oh [ __ ] you're throwing a
lot of faints and he's trying to cut off
the cage because obviously they've
studied your movement but again you
can't really train for your movement so
i think it's easier said than done when
the coach goes cut off the cage yeah oh
way easier you know what i'm saying like
look at your movement here i'm juking
back and forth
just constantly stutter stepping and
then when i also not you wasting energy
you know what i'm saying like you look
at some guys like dude you're gonna
[ __ ] gas out i'm not worried about
your movement guessing out yeah i can do
this all day god that hair is [ __ ]
lit dude i can't get enough of it so
look at this uppercut look at that that
punch right there is the one i knocked
him out with but i just threw it just
now though earlier three minutes 50
seconds left you hit him with an
uppercut right i faked the uppercut left
hand right hand that's where hit me with
the right hand but uh did it hurt i
remember feeling it i don't remember
being like oh [ __ ] i can't get hit by
that again but i was like okay i got hit
by right hand just like being aware of
it he's i remember his corner could be
on tyson tyson so i was assuming he was
either a two-three or three-two
but it was weird because you could hear
in the in there you could hear the guy
everything yeah yeah
which can be somewhat of a distraction
because if they know you're listening
they throw code words exactly like you
fight no guerra yeah you never know
they're trying to trick you or they're
that's what set it all up that's a liver
shot i dropped so many people with that
liver i don't know how easy to stand
that hurt you could tell that hurt look
at his movement and then you go back to
the kick that right hand landed then
you're trying to take him out there but
he's definitely wobbled here like he's
oh my god dude and it was a silent in
there all you hear was
like it was
crazy and one of the best parts too is
you're pretty good herb deems it goes to
step in and i'm like i'm in such a
relaxed like he pushed me i kind of like
fall just because i'm so relaxed in
there you expected that i knew once i
heard him with that liver shot dude when
you hurt someone liver shot if they
don't drop you know they're in some
serious [ __ ] pain
i also think with that liver shot too it
shows you how tough [ __ ] eddie
weinland is like most
99 of the time people are going to drop
there's your coach yep
team look at that
healthy dude brandon strength
conditioning coach
yeah that so those two years off like
this is my second fight with those two
years off i started i lifted i first
time i ever got a lifting program dude
you look like a different human being
well i was eating a vegan diet before
not i was for a little bit for that
fight and then my debut i was so two
fights but that's why vegan
i don't hate on my mom's vegetarian
i think i i was just trying trying new
[ __ ] dude i wanted to feel what just try
a new thing what if it could have been
great it wasn't but it could have been
and uh
her like watching me walk off herbs like
pushes me away i'm like i'm already
walking come on yeah i mean that's just
him like making sure he was snoring
yeah that's tough and rogan said it was
one of the he said the best knockout or
a walk-off ko has ever seen it's pretty
filthy i think mark hunt might have
something to say
he's like he's
supposed to he's the biggest i'm 35 or
we're not supposed to walk off cam fair
point
fair point
eddie what a nice guy dude like a
genuine legend dude
when i knock people out i i genuinely as
the val kilmer mustache from tombstone
too yeah that's [ __ ] up
yeah that one was uh do your coach try
and pretend he's has a mask on i know he
dude everything it's just covering his
mouth
we go on flights and he's like dude hey
we the guy we put matthew
redheads poor
friends
poor eddie man i know and then you feel
for him but also this is the power
just left out his body you know it
[ __ ] hurt dude and you're comp he's
like [ __ ] dude yeah i remember just
close my eye i like the clothes just
like really take it in if you just feel
rather than see
the legend continues yeah
that builds the legend so that was 2000
[Music]
no 2020 i think
2020 to 2030 is the sugar [ __ ] era
yeah because that was like the you got
the apec center with not many fans that
yeah it's 2020 when the far left top not
bottom left
boom
so this is your most recent fight
uh pavia again first time fighting
someone younger
oh [ __ ] yeah that's 26. which was kind
of interesting i mean it doesn't i mean
again i didn't i wasn't crazy about this
fight free just because i'm aware of
this dude and the experience that he has
tough sleeper yeah like it's a tough
night in the office like he's not gonna
he's not being scared of the hype like
look at this [ __ ] crowd man insane
dude when i walked out so this is the
opening of a main card
when i walked out to fight chris montino
opening main card connor versus dustin
it wasn't like this really when i
[ __ ] when i walk for the yeah open to
the main when i walked out for this
fight that [ __ ] was [ __ ] packed and
they were there for the [ __ ] sugar
show dude they really were like this was
charles versus dustin but i swear to god
that [ __ ] were there for the
sugar show and you said that yeah build
up you're like they're here for me this
is this is my show here it's still
pretty lit
yeah no i meant that that hairs
anytime she does hair it's gonna be
[ __ ] sweet but yeah and the fourteen
oh you already know see i thought
fourteen no i think the the minus 350 i
think that was being gracious because
the whoever made the odds obviously i
believe in your skill set right but just
with his wrath i think with 1992 or
something you're talking about and
coming off like he fought my buddy kyler
phillips who i trained with and kyle's a
[ __ ] yeah dude he's gonna be
he's gonna be in the top five champ like
he's gonna run the division and me and
him are gonna be up there like and and
he just fought piva who i i thought kyle
won the fight even if you
the worst comes worst scenario it was a
draw it was a crazy [ __ ] fight but i
know how good kyler is and i'm like and
he was able to go with the distance i'm
like [ __ ] this motherfucker's good dude
good black belt trains out alpha male 1
yeah so yeah you're at faber in this
corner
when i fight someone i want i have to
want to hurt them i could never fight
him i just have a mutual respect for him
for him and i've had you know small
conversations with him but dude i just
really think he's a good dude and i
would not want to knock him out smart
dude too brilliant business man
you're ready to go for this one you got
the
69 tattoo
that was my first six night attack ufc
269.69 was supposed to be there
halle berry halle bear who else i think
jared leto's in the crowd jerry leto is
my biggest fan dude it no way yeah god
you don't know who i am and i'm such a
fan he's my spirit animal we're boys oh
yeah he was at my last fight too we got
a sick pick was blacked out really
[Laughter]
but here early on keeping the body i'm
not gonna throw any low legs what's the
game plan here a teep stay away okay
because you knew he was gonna try i'm
not gonna try to kick him in the legs
i'm not gonna try to kick him in the
head i'm gonna t because you don't want
him to take you down yep no take notes
because i haven't grappled in three
weeks here i did not know where my ribs
were i did not see right there look at
that throws a little leg kick pull out
and dc is like i don't know why they
don't try to kick him in the leg oh my
come on he just [ __ ] tried
but uh yeah just constantly you know my
people that watch my family faint a lot
and stay on the outside the faints are
brilliant stop his [ __ ] knee yep
and uh
just just uh you know i was i didn't
know
you you find out where your cardio is at
when you spar three rounds with a fresh
guy each round you really know where
your card is i didn't get to do that
so did you have nerves going into the
fight because that's just very confident
i feel like i was just in control of my
mind and i knew i had the right thoughts
threat right thought processes go into
this that's that championship mentality
i have a championship mindset dude
that's [ __ ]
i gotta show it to myself in this fight
yeah you're proving something yourself
yeah having the perfect camp still
fighting a monster a lot of pressure
main card opening fight on the main
screen so this is got jared leto right
there definitely not in the nuts they
show another angle and it kind of looks
but that right that was not in the nuts
let me see it's like still right on the
belt line but i think if it was a nut
shot he would have hurt more and i think
in the moment you get hit it's close you
don't know you're like [ __ ] like ah
you don't know but he he played it off
to where he was good so i see jared leto
back there in the hoodie
right here
the jab jab the disc frustrated him yes
now he's starting to come and that's
what i want right he's also missing you
you're trying to lead him in to get the
knockout i want him to just over commit
on some [ __ ] right there barely miss
with that right hand throwing a left of
the body make i always mix it up well
body legs head
and when i say legs i was doing a lot
more leg stomps this fight rather than
and you can feel him start to over
commit a little bit yeah he's i'm i'm
fine if you guys want to pressure me you
can go ahead i'm gonna [ __ ] do you think
this is gonna be a first round ko
i think in a lot of the interviews i
said i just don't see it going out of
there but i also knew how tough he was
so i was like i'm ready for 15. i kept
saying that because mentally i was but i
guess physically i thought that's a good
shape too um
oh that was that would have been clean
he's pressured hey look at the clock
right there i'm not [ __ ] gassed out i
look at the clock i want to know which
time is it yeah what time i got left
dc doesn't say that again now that he
knows what yeah and in dc i think he's
like you should have just told me that
rather just come out but yeah but dc
don't fighters are sensitive yeah
dancing on a big cage man i [ __ ] love
that big beautiful left hand there just
i think for you to flourish we need the
bigger cage i'm never going to find the
small cage again
and now when they tell you for your next
side you go what size of the octagon it
well if it's in vegas and t-mobile we're
good if it's at the apex it's small yes
in vegas i don't fight anywhere other
than bags and i told you i've seen why
would you exactly i don't get why you
guys do it i don't know you have the
power to do it land a nice little leg
kick there but he's trying to go for the
legs but you're not giving him much to
work with because your movement even if
he does land it's like it's my leg's not
going to shut off like the keto fight
like i still have
you can tell it was in his game plan
though yeah of course and i know that
going into my fights people kick my legs
put me up because of the fence good luck
dude it looks like you've busted up his
nose though yeah when i uh see you land
a nice little leg kick there little chat
little land but
good thing
that's where i might have broke my hand
her thumb right there just like landed
on the side of his head
he's [ __ ] he's quick
he's [ __ ] yeah he's pressuring
i do 20 and was he 21 and two yeah
something like that yeah
well every time i get up against the
fence like that i'm blowing left right
you don't know which way you're gonna go
circle back in the middle
you're a tough uh problem to solve for
these guys to cut off the cage man so
right here i hit him with a [ __ ] the
first right hand tanquino he speaks
portuguese he listened to a full podcast
and the kid said yeah if i get hurt i'm
not scared to like back up take a step
so i [ __ ] and he told me that i hit him
with his right hand and in my head i'm
like wow that i know that hurt him but i
got it was validated when he did kind of
step back and reset now because he said
that if he gets hurt yeah he told him he
was like hey dude and like and did you
you already land the right hand here
yeah i landed here in a second
he's it's tough for him to touch him man
so he's getting frustrated yeah he's
getting frustrated yes
boom that right hand should watch him
take a step back
i'm like okay i heard him there's
another teeth in the same right hand
faint low
this is the full oh god switch stance
southpaw now southpaw just
nick diaz
uh hook hook hook body head that's nick
d as a [ __ ] right there
hook got it
there you go oh
god damn that felt legend continues it
felt so good like i just was so relieved
where's where's the jump shot thing come
from
will it well i think i first did it when
the suns were in the where uh in the
championship and then oh my god kept
doing it yeah and then right after steve
threw me this chain over the cage
because steve was front row
uh
and that was [ __ ] dope
i gotta find that picture of uh
of what jay letto oh you all know uh
jared leto yeah
i think he's 50. is he really yeah what
the [ __ ] i think he drinks like baby
deer blood i don't know what's going on
he's such a timepiece
boom dude that right hand was god i
can't believe he didn't go out jared
leto is yelling for you
wow what a picture and that's that's you
with jared leto and the guys from uh
what band are they from they're [ __ ]
uh uh chainsmokers oh [ __ ]
really yeah you just found out that's
the chainsmoker what the [ __ ] that's
sick i didn't know that yeah they're
massive god i got blacked out after the
chris boutinia fight jumped in head
first into a pool it tips after
everyone's looking i jumped in
it was like
two feet bro i hit my head my head was
bleeding [ __ ] sake that's in vegas
yeah that's the one
fight i did yeah that's a good night
though huh oh yeah i mean i think
i don't remember look at you with the
free throw the jump shot the fade away
that felt that was the booster relief
you felt good huh oh god because it just
i just first time going into a fight
like injured other than the contender
series where i was concussing a shitty
camp but that felt like so long ago it's
like a first big ufc fight i'm like this
is we'll see let's go but and then now
it's off to the right because even after
that dan's like we got to pay this kid
that yep that was the five days like hey
dude
which which i feel like i've
that's the way you got to do it even
young fighters coming up like don't ask
for money go out there and perform
correct what's going on you got to
become undeniable you just got to
[ __ ] go out there you got the chain
on and uh steve will do it through the
chain through it to me and then tim put
it on backwards so it's just like the
back of the chain
so it doesn't it's not like
and then you got three other ones now
yeah steve actually gave me this one too
okay so what is steve the greatest guy
of all time oh [ __ ] yeah i mean [ __ ]
good dude he was that he was that front
row wearing my [ __ ] 13-0 pink sugar
jersey that's dumb
bro i love you bro good dude you deserve
it man these are fun to do oh it's fun
watching your fights no that was that
was [ __ ] dope thank you i appreciate
that appreciate you brother well uh yeah
man i can't thank you enough for being
the the first fighter to come out here
when we're you know we're not in show
times thick boy production dude so
i think we're doing a lot more of this
man yeah we'll do the setup you got here
like i was telling tim too and i was
telling you like our setup is this is
this is goals this is what we want our
setup to be like like this so this is
[ __ ] sweet to come being able to like
check it out i feel like this is in your
future yeah you're america i've been
doing this for about nine years oh yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i think you're getting
their tracking in there yeah [ __ ] yeah
excited for your next fight more excited
for the next hairstyle you're gonna do
we'll see what's your luck brother thank
you bro take care of that hand enjoy the
whiskey
a little bit of work don't scare us i
get up i go hard like i'm george harris
make plays break lanes push weight break
chains go hard kick ass take names